you might want to watch this next
segment lying down many americans are
dealing with anxiety over the outcome of
the 2020 presidential election
according to a recent survey from the
american psychological association
more than two-thirds of adults say the
election has
been a significant source of stress in
their lives
that's up from 52 percent four years ago
board certified
psychiatrist dr sue varma is here to
help us with some simple ways
to manage your anxiety sue i wanted to
do this segment on a couch but
maybe you can what can we do because
there was enough stress
before this just dealing with the
coronavirus
now with all this uncertainty what
what's a good way to approach this
absolutely you know and when it comes to
uncertainty i kind of look at it as this
like blank
canvas or silent film if you will in
which we happen to project our worst
thoughts and it's kind of called
catastrophizing
and one of the things that we can do is
you know this election for me the theme
has been that people are trying to
change the things that they cannot
accept
but then at a certain point where we are
right now we have to accept the things
that we cannot change
and so much of the pandemic has been
fighting a battle on two fronts dealing
with all of the stuff that's happening
outside
with people getting sick and losing jobs
and protests
um wildfires hurricanes but then there's
the mental health challenges so what's
going on in our own head and that's what
i really want people to focus on right
now is that we we did our due diligence
up until this point in terms of
advocating and being activists in our
community and voting and at this point
we have to take care of our mental
health so
you know i'd love to share some simple
tips that everybody can do
but it it doesn't help when you have a
leaf blower like alone in your ear
either the home of anxiety
exactly exactly yes
[Laughter]
i want to pick up sue on on what anthony
was saying about
listen it was already thought that
election day would be one of the most
stressful
days of the year but as anthony pointed
out we've got corona
we've got job loss we've got economy
we've got racial unrest
we've got social discord so how in the
world do you cope when you've got
so many different levels of stress and
anxiety
absolutely so look you know when it
comes to anxiety we talk about the
productive aspect of it which is what
helps you make an action plan so are
there things in your life
that need taken care of so look you know
looking for the job
taking care of your health but then
there's the um unproductive anxiety
which is where our wheels are spinning
and that's where the
you know sort of tips can come in where
are you able to distract yourself and
self-suit those are kind of
distractions self-soothing grounding and
one thing that i'm finding extremely
beneficial that we don't talk about
enough is the role of nature in mental
health and you know in many parts of the
world this is now becoming a
prescription
we find that nature can be extremely
grounding it can lower your heart rate
it can lower your blood pressure
and you know what's really interesting
is that in the prior election in 2016
in just a couple of days after the
election there were more
hospitalizations for cardiac related
symptoms
palpitations people feeling dizzy
thinking that they were
having a heart attack so getting out in
nature can really be good for not only
your cardiac health but also your mental
health
and we found that a lot of times people
just looking at green spaces
it was calming and you don't have to be
out hiking in the mountains we're just
talking about the park down the street
from you
people who are able to spend two and a
half hours a week not in a day in a week
so breaking it up in small chunks
and being in green spaces found less
anxiety and less depression so being in
nature is huge
if you have pets if anyone you know has
pets spend time with them that source of
unconditional love
bonding with children with people that
you love if you're able to do it in a
safe way
oxytocin is a huge cuddle hormone so all
of these things are important
movement especially before 10 am in the
morning getting access to daylight
daytime sunlight that's huge because our
sleep insomnia
problems with that is really big right
now yeah all right dr sue varma thank
you very much and since you mentioned
the cuddle
hormone but cuddling wasn't on the
bullet sheet there i think we should add
cuddling
i think dogs nature i will say on the
nature thing central park has been my
savior in this
central park i don't know what i would
have done without it said that so and
she's
she's dead on we need to follow your
advice about that